[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the tony
michaels podcast and this is tony
michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
good morning good morning good morning
good morning we have a great interview
for you today we play
trivia
with
one of your favorite comedians i know
i know he is i know you've seen his
videos
about the the trump rallies
the insurrection we talk about all that
in the interview today we also play
trivia with walter masterson we were
excited um to finally air this we did
this several weeks ago and we're finally
excited to air this interview with
walter we've had several other things
with the ukraine news and the russian
news and everything going on but we're
very excited very excited to finally
finally finally show the interview that
we did with walter it's very fun and uh
by the way it's it's a extra long
interview so what we did is we we cut
some of it so what we'll do is maybe
over the weekend we'll replay the
entirety of the interview it's about two
hours long we wanted to do a little bit
of shitless roundup today so we'll play
uh the abbreviated interview today it
includes trivia we're going to show you
the trivia because
uh i couldn't even hardly hold it
together during the trivia couldn't even
hardly hold it together of course
with walter
hilarious
so uh stay tuned
today um here in about 15 minutes we'll
start the interview and then we'll do
[ __ ] list roundup for the last
30 45 minutes of the show because we're
on two hours a day every single day
every single [ __ ] weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific right here on youtube
twitter twitch
you guys know where we're partnered with
midas touch now they've been tweeting
out the broadcast so you guys can find
us
please please please subscribe to the
youtube channel do all those youtube
things you know go down like subscribe
comment down below all that kind of [ __ ]
right do everything that you're supposed
to do on the youtube
here
on the youtube and if you if you like to
listen to podcast we're on all the
directories even the boycotted ones
spotify apple google i heart radio you
name it we got it go to
thetonymichaels.com
and all the links are there
you can go to
podcast.dtonymichaels.com as well but go
to thetonymichaels.com all the links are
there the social media links the podcast
links the youtube channel if you want to
watch on twitch it's over there you can
follow me you can follow gabe follow
follow the podcast on twitter at tony
michael's pod we have the bonehead of
the week poll came out this morning
don't miss your chance to vote
this is the democracy here and we want
to practice
we want to practice voting so go over to
the tony michaels uh pod
at tonymichaelspodpage
on twitter
and take the poll the bonehead of the
week we got three great ones on there of
course donald john trump
representative madison cawthorne
and that
homophobe
ron desantis down in florida
for the don't say gay bill that piece of
[ __ ]
so go over and vote for the bonehead of
the week it is going to be a close race
i think
it's going to be a close race between
desantis
and donald john trump
it really is it really is shitty that
there's two
two florida men
on the
bonehead of the week
but what are you gonna do what the hell
you gonna do
the bonehead's gonna bonehead that's
just how it is i wanna say hello to
everyone here
oh my gosh we have leah we have we have
patty we have kathy we have debbie we
have everyone's here ann is here uh
lisa's here mj's here robin's here
nolan's here
uh um
thank you midas lisa for the super chat
you guys know we have super chat now
we have super chat if you'd like to uh
contribute to the show we like your
likes your comments your retweets
your subscribes your follows but if
you'd like to contribute
to the show you can also go to the super
chat you can do a super chat or you can
do a super sticker they're there as well
who else we have here we um i don't want
to miss anybody but boy we got some new
faces here we got kevin
uh we got christina's here good morning
good morning all david is here
good morning to all of you
mayo is here mayo made it
thank you for joining us here on the
tony michaels podcast again every single
weekday for all you new listeners
everyone out there to all union
listeners we're on youtube twitter
twitch noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific
two hours every single weekday and it's
live
live tv live tv mj says love love you
all
thanks for the super chat
mj we love you
everyone here loves mj mj's
always here
always here never misses we appreciate
you mj and and mj also she always uh she
was in jail recently i think
because of the bone end of the week poll
um
i guess i guess she commented about
lauren bobo the bobo the clown got put
in jail she's out on bail now though be
careful nj be careful
keep sending those dms though and anyone
who wants to dm me uh tweets that you'd
like to try to get onto the podcast
you're welcome to do that dms are open i
believe if i follow you and you follow
me you can send me a dm you can also tag
me in a post as well
and if i'm not following you on twitter
don't stress out about it all you got to
do is just tag me somewhere say hey
follow me
i'm not stingy with the follows i'll
follow you it doesn't make me no
difference i like to follow anyone who
follows me it's just hard to get around
to every single one of them
but uh carter's here is is
is chris in here our our local hate
watcher chris ann is probably here
probably watching every single day
watching
so i appreciate you joining us uh we're
gonna get to the interview here really
quick uh gabe gabe it looks like he's
trying to come in uh there he is there
he is uh gabe how are you this morning
were you not ready
no i was
oh oh you got walter's name on the
whiteboard even
yeah yeah okay good good good i i i
we've been wanting to air this interview
for a while we've had it in the can
yeah yeah yeah i don't know
the whole this whole morning has been
like
oh yeah
piled on
it's honestly it's just like murphy's
law you know it's like i tried to start
the morning and get things going and
everything just went wrong oh yeah well
you know it it's probably that soda
stream i don't know if do you do the
sodastream thing in the morning i don't
i do the soda stream in the morning
i'm just wondering listen man i just
wondering i'll just say this i didn't
have
my soda stream this morning maybe that's
maybe that's the reason do you do do you
stream your coffee is it do you do that
no i don't drink coffee what coffee's
disgusting all right all right all right
i did not know this about gabe uh he
does not drink coffee this is not i
don't not sufficient devil juice okay
devil devil juice what what makes coffee
so bad and soda is just so carbonated
water and it's grow like okay look i've
had coffee
six times in my life i want to see this
is probably the problem is it's i've had
i've tried starbucks i tried stumptown
i've tried
uh
uh what have i tried um
stop right there i've tried all the like
have you ever just have you ever just
made a cup of coffee like yeah as a kid
i just need my parents cups of coffee
like i can make a cup of coffee is that
what your parents drank what's yours
no no no no no they drank some other
good stuff i don't know good stuff what
what's wrong with folgers what's wrong
with folgers this is not
you know
listen isn't it the one that like the
wake you up one best part of waking up
and this is the whistle right right yeah
yeah that seat that's you know that's
why no i know it i know it i just only
know it as the uh and hey i i mean i'm
not a coffee guy so i won't knock it but
what i will say
is i just don't like coffee just in
general i've tried i've tried uh every
type of coffee i've tried from the you
know if you've tried six types and it's
every type every kind six is the only
thing
i tried i tried latte i've tried
cappuccino i've tried coffee i've you
know it look it look i've tried every i
i even tried like the first one i tried
was a vanilla latte from starbucks it
would be like oh maybe the sugar will
help to like you know maybe that's
this is the problem you're putting too
much you're putting too much thought
into it i drink it
i just drink coffee flavored coffee i
don't even put anything in mine that's
great i don't even i just don't think
about coffee
because i don't want coffee so i don't
put a lot of thought into it because i
put no thought into it wow and you know
how much money i save
tons
of money
coffee right like if you just if you
just make your own coffee like in a pot
or even like that still costs money i
need the pot it's way the machine
possibly i need pods i need filters i
need mugs
not to mention the coffee beans or
grounds
and also potentially the grinder i mean
let's just
okay okay so let's let's ask let's ask
uh
someone who is a a show to stream
aficionado how much does it cost to
stream your own your own water well it
depends on which unit you want you know
it could be like 40 to 80 bucks let's
say based on any filters is there
filters no voltage there's no filters
but then you some people are so
dedicated they'll run in like a big co2
tank and then have it that way which is
economically it makes sense
but what i do is i go to bed bath and
beyond
if you guys want to sponsor us bed bath
beyond let me know no no no no uh we're
not getting sodastream
uh co2 canisters
and uh when you get them then you can
exchange them at a lower rate when you
go to bed bath beyond so you're not
buying a new one each time you know so
you take it environmentally friendly
yeah it's just a big cancer it's like
this
this big so is it is bed bath and beyond
the only place that you can that you can
get these things you could probably get
them other places but that's the only
one that i know of and that's the only
one that has a are they right next to
the my pillows are where the my pillows
were is it uh no they're not that close
to where they were on the store i think
the bedding section was like it's off in
the back area by the curtains i didn't
know if it had like a as seen on tv
section and that's right well they do
have that but it's uh they no longer
carry my pillows right i we you know i'm
sure they're still trying to sell them
well i mean who knows they could be
using them as just like a packing
stuffer you know right right right like
with their shipping stuff online exactly
yeah yeah they're like just rip open the
pillows and the packing peanuts are in
there because that's basically what they
are right i was gonna say the packing
peanuts are inside exactly that's good
see see we don't only talk about
politics on this show we we break down
important issues like coffee soda stream
where the my pillows are if they are in
the bed bath and beyond and are they
next to the sodastream
co2 canisters real important stuff here
on the tony michael's podcast we discuss
the things that matter on this that's
right that's right the things that
matter
in um the politics because here's the
thing i'm not the only one who does this
i'm sure there's another listener at
least one please be at least one and
either it's strange
coffee
and or also
buys
uh
sodastream co2 canisters from there
there's not they're just i'm sure
there's actually one out there there's
probably not somebody speak up please
like you are the only one keeping
sodastream in business at this point
that's totally fine and again if
sodastream wants to sponsor the show i
will happily accept a deal from that
i i wouldn't i wouldn't um kick him out
of bed for um eat notes as they say so
all right let's get to the let's get to
the uh the interview walter is hilarious
and not only is hilarious but he he has
produced the last um you know really
since the pandemic and he talks about it
in this interview right like how he
started to go to the rallies and stuff
like that this is also just wanna this
is also uh we did this interview before
he even went to the ottawa trucker yes
yes
correct correct yeah it was about a week
before that i guess wasn't it yeah i
don't know if that's what he's referring
to well in an extended part of the
interview right he talks about he's got
some upcoming stuff that he can't really
talk about so i don't know if that's it
but right well well and we're going to
release the extended interview probably
sometime this weekend i don't know if
we'll premiere it like live air it or if
we'll just drop it on youtube and send
you guys the link so you can go find it
we'll we'll make that decision we'll do
that sometime this weekend
um probably on sunday is when we'll do
that to to get the the extended version
because i i think it's about two hours
so we're missing about half of the whole
interview yeah
so we're close to two hours yeah yeah so
so so stay tuned um with the interview
with walter next um it's about an hour
long and we play trivia in the interview
and it's that like we can't even like me
and you can't even hold it together
during the trivias
you got to stick around for the trivia
it's it's ridiculously funny but also
also check out this week and check out
the extended uh version on the youtube
channel you're going to want to
subscribe to the youtube channel to find
that and we'll try to send out links or
we'll air it live and i'll give you a
live airing of it so you can see it on
twitch
and twitter as well
um also stick around after the interview
because we're gonna go through the [ __ ]
list roundup i don't you're pretty busy
i don't know if will you be able to join
us after the interview you think for a
little bit of [ __ ] list i'm going to try
okay sounds good but yeah all right well
here's another one
i love you all there there you go
and and and he'll be streaming soda
as yeah if i'm not streaming this show
i'm streaming soda baby that's right
that's right a live streamer
soda streamer
some might say i was the original
streamer
all right stick around right after the
break for walter's interview and then
stick around for the the second hour of
the show we're going to go through the
shitless roundup here we go
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv
slash the tony michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show we have a
special guest for you this afternoon
you guys know his videos definitely um
he's been right next to matt gatz the
sex trafficker marjorie taylor green and
a few others
he is a comedian and satirist walter
masterson walter thank you for joining
us we are excited it's we've been trying
to get you on the show for a while now
you're you're a little uh elusive there
you've been running around the country
making videos
yeah i'm always i'm always happy to to
be with you guys i mean you're my peeps
um yeah i've uh i'm gonna be doing some
more traveling soon some uh some things
i can't talk about right now oh is this
some secret [ __ ] yeah a big announcement
that you you'll see yeah okay
um but yeah thank you yeah thanks for
coming yeah we're happy to have you uh
you're welcome back any time really
honestly
you know
especially if you have secret
information that you can you know have
secret information about the deep states
coming from george soros
yeah and it was like i mean you know i'm
going to complain a little bit and be
like my baby that that was you know had
the adrenochrome was like late this week
it was like
okay soros you know what i mean i was
like you know
i mean i know it's like common it's like
everyone said when you signed up it was
like listen you know
soros has to pay you through cnn she
can't pay you directly so it takes a
while sometimes your check is going to
be late and so i mean you know i'm
complaining but obviously i knew this
going in right right well you know i
actually i actually laminated my i
didn't know you could you weren't
supposed to do this i laminated my
antifa membership card so that way when
i put it in my fanny pack that it
doesn't get all crumpled up but
apparently you're not supposed to it's
not official anymore if you don't
laminate it
oh he's muted oh
we can't hear you
unless he's purposely doing this i don't
know
we can't hear you how are you muted
well
okay so that's that's the funniest
because i would the entire time i was
talking about getting paid by george
soros
so wait a second did george soros mute
your microphone i did i just did my mic
just get muted it just got like so i
don't think so any any details
that i just did
about
how sometimes the baby is late and
sometimes i don't they give me the wrong
baby and i don't know until like i bite
into it oh yeah no yeah he soros heard
it and he was like ah yeah
i said antifa membership card you were
saying george soros so it's like and
then i suddenly just got muted and i
wasn't even touching it it was whatever
right too much so so back to the george
soros thing because gabe gets us a lot
i've had this before they're like oh
you're paid operative or some [ __ ] like
that but like you're you've been
he's still muted they're muting us it's
wrong what is happening they don't know
okay i'm gonna look at my thing right
now because i'm just gonna all right so
um
i've i've had people say that to my face
that george soros is paying him to be
here
to you like they're saying that about
you about me to me right i showed up at
an to an anti-vaxx rally with this
massive check um made out to me from
george soros where do i cache this i
think i remember i think i remember this
video i think i remember it was like a
huge check and it was it was actually
funny because i've i've moved multiple
times and while i'm moving like i keep
my stuff
in like bags in like the lobby and
outside my door and then so you have all
these like passersby like in the place
i'm leaving and moving into like seeing
this massive
like publishers clearing house size
george soros back
and it's so absurd like
where the hell did you have this [ __ ]
thing made at i mean is it a real check
from george soros or did you have it
made somewhere is this it's just i like
i call like this prince
place
for like 40 bucks it was great um
it reminds me of that scene from semi
pro where will ferrell gives him the big
check and he's like hey i'm having
trouble like working cash in he's like
you just gotta take it to i think he
says like you gotta take it to a big
bank and just like cash it there and
he's like okay and he just carries the
big check out of the parking lot
exactly there's this one uh shot in this
anti-vax rally where this woman jumps in
front of my cameraman and says george
soros now we know who he's working for
and she's just
understood serious she's not kidding at
all i have long conversations with this
woman she's convinced i was like wow
okay
whatever like they're like we're all
paid to be there
right yeah like i was like we were paid
we were paid to be there so so let me
ask you do you think that is projection
because you've been in these crowds
right you've been to some of these
rallies and and a lot of people you look
at like behind trump when he's doing his
rallies it's a lot of the same people
like it's a lot of the same people i a
lot of people swear that you know he's
paying this i don't think they have
no i can't we can't he can't hear you
can't hear you it's totally
it's totally sorrows so we were talking
about um
the trump rally they don't there's so
many cultist people that show up to
these rallies they don't need to find
they don't need to pay anyone
because i've been to a lot of them i've
seen familiar faces
i'm going there to make comedy so i'm
there's like a very
like there's a reason for me to be there
but these people
follow him to rally to rally
you know as if it's a band right so
they're like groupies weirds me out i
see like i've seen the same people at
this and i'm like
like i can understand if this was a band
like he just did the same thing
yesterday like i was at the thing
yesterday and now look what are you
doing
um like i mean i can understand why i'm
there
right
what would you i mean you know like like
they are your comedy right they they oh
they oh they they're i love them
i love them i mean
i
if i i will never find a better
comedic partner
improvisationally i mean they're just
yeah they're so with it
it's i mean
yeah republicans you know
like correspondents anchors whoever they
are like they are
just like
okay they just they do a great job they
set you up and then you're like great
spike boom done oh dude i mean and i
mean we just we just we it's like
[ __ ] jazz dude we just jam it out
like and so my whole thing is i've done
this a while my whole you know it's a
tactic that i'm using is you know you
load up the front of the sentence with
something to where they won't hear the
end right like you get them so angry
like there's certain words you say it
and they lose their [ __ ] there's words i
don't even say around them you don't
accuse anyone of being racist in that
crowd
because they will lose their [ __ ] with
you you say the word racist and they
will like god god damn it
and i was like whoa okay wow
they're mad about being called a racist
not about actual racism
don't let you call other people racists
that aren't them that are against them
and like yeah they're the racists it
doesn't exist but if it does exist it's
the democrats
you know there's nothing you know
systemic racism i mean come on you know
but you know but i mean of course let's
talk about joe biden's 94 crime bill
right right right well yeah i mean
obviously the democrats are racist
because they started the kkk you know
you've probably heard that [ __ ] before
i've heard that so many times i've heard
these ones it's like
um
and it's it's this like insidious lie
that they're spreading it's a great way
to attract
you know black you know bipod black
indigenous people of color to their side
um because i mean you know they're just
saying hey you've been [ __ ] over by
everyone right and you know like you
think the democrats are any better come
with us
and you know we're
we're gonna you know help you with free
enterprise god damn it um you know we
want you to succeed as opposed to those
people um but yeah and it's this
incident there's so much insidious lies
like the democratic thing it was like
you know so they talk about how they
invented the kkk they're racist i had a
whole post on that where i was saying
all right
you know they passed the civil rights
bill democrats passed two civil rights
bills and a voting rights bill in the
60s and the ones the democrats that
weren't didn't like that left right
after that
um you know there was that was a big
deal right it's like a party switch or
something right
and then nixon came acro came along and
said hey you don't have to be democrat
to win in the south anymore right and
then they were like oh
whoa okay
so yeah and then they were like and
we're gone
and it's always like funny because it's
like
i wanted to do more of with that because
you know they're you know the party of
lincoln freed right yeah right
it was like well you're also advocating
for the confederate flag too right right
right like
like they got a confederate flag shirt
on and like oh we love lincoln like that
his face just plastered it's like you
guys got to pick a lane it's one or the
other which one is it you guys
like it this way or you don't like it
this way but it can't be both so have
you have you become like because you see
these people so often sometimes
you see do you know them by like name
and you're like oh that this is the ones
in new york
know me very well i don't i can't really
hide out because they've seen me so much
even in your costumes and stuff because
you sometimes wear like i've actually
done less costuming i used to like i
used to wear a mask glasses hat through
one of my earliest videos you wouldn't
know who i was i had a mask a hat and
glasses sunglasses you didn't you
couldn't see me in it and then i've
been progressively less disguised as
i've gone on because i've realized that
it's actually frightening because
they live in a different world we live
in a different world right right it's so
fragmented our society they don't see
our videos they don't see my videos they
don't see your
it's
some of them
if they did it's like a blip
right i i thought like oh it's because i
keep going to these things going
they're going to start recognizing me
and they're going to be waiting for me
that's not the case
i'm honestly yeah i'm so surprised that
no one has recognized you i'm just
there's
sometimes when i go i've been at places
like i was in florida and one person
was online and she smirked at me she
looked at me like oh i know
i know
you work with me like oh there you go
didn't you did you get kicked out of
like an official republican event in
texas or something or uh
not yet not not yet yeah not yet
hopefully soon though right
maybe there's nothing right of a trump
uh is that bill o'reilly thing for
screaming [ __ ] oh yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah okay that was
[ __ ] um and in hindsight i was like
yeah i don't want to
like openly challenge like 10 000 people
at once so so the other question i have
about some of the rallies because you
posted a video the other day
uh or at least i seen it the other day i
think on instagram where um they locked
in the lady are they locked in the the
the support
arizona okay so i'll start from the
beginning so
trump's like
return rally his you know
the one at wellington ohio back in june
i
took a 360 degree unedited video
of people leaving i was actually kind of
surprised i was i his followers love him
they worship him i was a little like huh
what are you doing why are you leaving
and this was while he's speaking though
right like he's speaking so it's a 360
degree unedited video you can hear him
talking
and you can see
hundreds if not thousands leaving
like leaving leaving and
me asking them why they're leaving
they're like kind of like
um
and it was unedited it was it was very
like
straightforward
brian williams when he was on uh was
11th hour he featured it um on his show
and it was amazing like he used it to
corroborate because the new york times
said it was a very lackluster
speech and people were bored and he goes
well you might think that's the liberal
media but we have proof and he just
shows my video
and i was like whoa
let's do this
fast forward to his rally the other week
in arizona
um
so the
tick tocker that recorded this
was special head
amazing guy he went there dressed as the
viking the cue shaman
these people
talking about how they can't leave this
this is this is where they were fenced
in right where they gated them in we
weren't allowed to leave early until
trump left until trump and the vips left
and they swore it was you know for
security reasons i've been to so many
other rallies that has never happened
security has been able to finesse
leaving
right
leaving's never been a problem for the
secret service
of
you know extracting a president from a
rally when there's traffic outside
oh no
all right not a not a baby not a big
deal yeah i mean also it's also not
uncommon for trump to just like peace
out and then leave everyone else to be
like yeah you find your own way home
i've been to so many of these what they
do is this you're you park so far away
from the venue
they don't let you anywhere near the
venue because obviously they don't want
you driving up with a truck full of
bombs and whatever and security i
totally understand that easy on the word
bomb there walter i know
yeah i know this is this does doesn't
yeah so um they don't want you
driving up with that so
um
whenever i've been to these the parking
is so far from the actual venue there's
sometimes you're shuttled sometimes
you're walking
it's so
it's always so then one of them was uh
yeah
there was no shuttle service back they
screwed up no shuttle service these
people were just left out there in some
corn field for like
you know hours on end
did you go to the rally uh the it was
like the first
big rally that they had i think it was
in alabama um after covid um
it was when the ivor mechton [ __ ]
started you know they that that story
had dropped and um it was just this huge
big deal down in alabama it was like out
in the middle of nowhere no i didn't go
to the alabama one um
yeah you mentioned i ever met i'm like
oh my god stop with the [ __ ] i can't
i [ __ ] can't with the ivermectin
it's still it's still going it's still
going it's still going
like they still can't figure it out
right they still can't figure i'm like
it's no but so i've been to cuenon
rallies okay so this is different than
is it is it visually different than the
trump rallies i mean or is it kind of
like conferences they talk at length
there's speakers all right okay and i
mean you know they
talk about hcq
and ivermectin like all the time like
just constantly puking it up or what
paul gosar was you know
this whole speech
looking to talk about how he got coveted
you know he's just gonna start with the
hcq regimen and i was like oh my god
like
oh like
god damn it this is this doesn't work
yeah right well and then they're
drinking piss you know well at least
last week they were drinking i think
they are i don't think i think there's
like too many people but yeah there's
probably very few people but sometimes
like heard that story and we just hoped
that it was everyone we were like yeah
it's probably like 10 people but
i'm
just hoping
that it's like a million that there's
just millions
just drinking their own piss yeah just
pissing on each other and they're like
wow get it in my mouth
[Laughter]
i mean knowing trump that's that would
be something he might do you know little
showers right golden showers yeah
yeah that's crazy so so what is what has
been
the the weirdest experience at a rally
like like you're like what in the [ __ ]
is this like was it was it from trump's
supporters was it from okay no you know
what okay
there's this story
oh my god and it was so because you you
spend a lot of time with these people
and it's tragic because you know they're
people they're human beings and right
you know they're decent and they're in
you know they're decent human beings
until they just open their mouth and
you're like
michelle obama's like sucking adrenal
cone from babies and you're like oh my
god stop um
so i went to the my pillow guy rally
um
okay
so this ride situation was screwed up
getting out of there and so we'd like
hitchhike
and i hitch we hitchhike with this
this woman who offered to drive us back
into town
lovely woman
awesome and we had this like incredibly
long conversation with her and she
was very dedicated
to fighting against child molestation
and she was talking about how you know
these certain communities and you know
the amish community and this and you
know and how they're she's like they're
covering up molestation
and they're sweeping it under the rug
and
and i was like oh wow and i was a i was
like a second away
from actually revealing that i actually
have a very big platform and then i
could i'd be happy to help you with this
thing i'm just so happy
and then she goes in on um
hillary clinton you know drinking the
blood of the adrenal chrome from babies
and i was like
okay didn't nope nope and now i don't
believe anything she said right yeah and
here's the problem here's what was very
insightful into the mind of someone that
believes in cunanan
this person had been repeatedly sexually
assaulted as a child by someone she knew
that was an upstanding member of the
community
now this is the thing with this whole
save the children q on thing
i've spoken to a lot of them a lot of
them have been assaulted
when they were younger
and then
it was by someone that was upstanding in
within the community
so of course when you tell them that
there's an upstanding politician that is
a pedophile
they have no problem believing it right
because they're predisposed to that
experience they're like yeah i the
person who molested me
was an upstanding member of the
community and they looked you know they
looked like a perfect uh citizen and all
of that and
it's a lot i mean it's not everyone but
it's enough of them where you're going
whoa
this is preying upon that
trauma right that you experience well
and also it could be too like like um
because i have some people in my family
that fell to q anon and
it's it seems like two like they take
experiences from other people they're
like oh i know about this experience
from this person right if you would know
the story about the neighbor or sister
or cousin that was assaulted by someone
and then you know you kind of
appropriate that story and then it's
easy to believe right if you believe if
you believe your cousin or your sister
or whatever and then here you are right
right right in lock step with this gun
yeah and it was it was like just tragic
to me because it just there's you meet a
bunch of people that and you're like god
damn it like i don't dislike you you're
decent you know you're a human being and
like the cue shaman i met him he's
a very decent energy he's one of those
people that when you're talking he's
very focused on you because you're
talking and he's going to give you all
of his attention
right you know and then that's what
messed me up after january 6 because i
met him i interviewed him it was
unremarkable interview i thought the guy
was absolutely crazy i did notice that
he was just very generous with his how
he gave you his full attention when you
were talking
right all those people that you know
you're talking he's focused on you he's
not looking at his phone he's looking at
you he's intently listening
and seems decent to talk to and
like altogether crazy everything he said
was crazy but i just watched him do this
crazy thing and i go this is this is the
problem it's we tend to think of
you know this extremism as a bunch of
fire brands when in fact it's like you
know decent people
being radicalized into doing really
awful things
do you think that the that so like for
instance the q and shaman do you think
that it the
the attention that he gave you was a
product of
of of him
not getting attention elsewhere and
being like this person is actually going
to listen to me and talk to me about
this thing
i feel like he's just one of those
people that's yeah you know he thinks
he's on you know the the right side
right right it's you know part of this
you know sort of
you know weird you know part of
christianity
and you know in that whole thing and
he's just very he actually believes all
of that like right the right wing people
claim they they're like we don't claim
him
we don't play i've got interviews or
people saying we don't claim this guy
he's not one of us even at the q and on
rallies they don't um they they all just
disparage him he's he's not part of us
he's not you know anyone that they don't
like they're like we don't that's he's
you know he's faking it he's just there
for attention so that is it the costume
that [ __ ] them up because that because
it because like when when you think of q
anon outside of their circle right like
that's one of the first images you see
is this guy and this [ __ ] shaman you
know with the horns and [ __ ] like that's
what you think of is oh that's kunan the
crazy guy in the costume that went to
the capitol so like so so they're like
no you're not one of us is it because of
his popularity and because it's kind of
like oh you're you're cleaning that's
because it's it's sort of
unmistakable what he did like he ran
right
like a lunar right
and he's like the face of this movement
right deny that he exists so they
they've denied that he's
with them
everyone that did anything bad on
january 6 was antifa
right yeah no one
there were no trump supporters that did
anything bad like it was all antifa and
it's not like you were there to see it
either right
[Laughter]
it was the weirdest thing like i just
having people tell me what happened i'm
like
no i was there what are you talking
about there's this guy in new york
um he there's like literal footage of
him
crawling through a broken window to gain
access to the capitol on january 6th
and the guy screams at me every time
because he got mad that i
called
january 6 writers domestic terrorists i
see him in new york all the time he
screams at me and you know i was behind
all of it i'm the racist i was behind
all of it i'm you know i'm a
covert white supremacist that i'm the
reason that's you know that the people
at january 6 were all demonized and
vilified is because of mike i was like
it never ends
right
it's it's like a lot of people called
darvo deny attack reverse
you know so where you victimize you so
so he was so he was there on january 6
and he committed a crime and he has not
he was prosecuted he was absolutely
prosecuted he was on the lower end of
the prosecutor yeah i got it okay a lot
of the people in the lower end just got
misdemeanors right um it's got it was
some light slap on the wrist
where they're not actually involved in
some of the conspiracy the actual
conspiracy to overthrow they were just
in the crowd and you know is that what
you is that what you seen
there were yeah i so what i saw was
first of all they're gonna a lot of them
claim that we didn't know what was going
on inside this it seemed so peaceful
right everyone knew what was going on
because people were coming out
and telling and reporting on what was
happening inside
well and they had their cell phones too
right so like they were communicating to
some degree on social media i knew what
was happening inside because people were
showing me footage and telling me what
was happening inside when they came out
there it was
it was actually very chill
for them for a few hours because they
were they had no resistance
none
you walked in you walked out no one
stopped you how close how close did you
get to the building when you were there
i was like up like on the you know
i
it's only somewhere in like the in my
video where like there's three sets of
steps going up the back
and i was like made it up of like i was
on the
second set of steps and i was about to
go up on the next set of steps to go
like up and in right and then someone
shows me like this picture of ashley
babbitt's head blown off and i was like
oh one o'clock yeah gotta go i was like
okay that's enough this is yeah you know
you know there was a lot of satirists
there you were there clepper was there
the good liars like there was you guys
went to this event because i mean they
made it a big deal right but also not
knowing what was gonna you were thinking
right it was just gonna be like a big
flop well i thought there was gonna be
people i didn't know the violence was
gonna be so concentrated i had been to
the stop to steal rallies
since right after the election and i
went there and i
shot these people and got interviews and
did comedy and i
and it was like progressively angrier
people the second one
like i i left that one crying the one in
december i left it like crying i was
messed up for a day or two i was like
because i had just met the absolute
craziest of the crazy
angriest of the angry like the angry the
anger in that air was palpable it was
weird i was like this is
it it was different it was different
it's way like there were people giving i
it felt surreal there was a guy giving a
speech saying aren't you sick of all
these fact checkers and i'm like why are
you sick of black deckers
where am i and like these people like
sharing they're like yeah
[ __ ] these fact checkers
and i was like what the [ __ ] is
happening
um
and it wasn't
it was just like there was that one was
like literally the craziest of the crazy
that was where i met the cue shaman and
then so
basically i knew to get out of dc before
sundown because every time you go to
these rallies
after sundown is when things get crazy
[ __ ] full moon comes out and they all
[ __ ] turn into even
yeah you know like what you know
[Laughter]
like just yeah and it was so i was like
and jolly good ginger who had been to
the other two with
he couldn't come
and see he was good to have us like
protection he's a former you know
military it's actually me and i've
talked and said it's actually good you
weren't there you would have played hero
it's actually glad i'm actually happy he
was not there
um because he probably would have gotten
badly hurt
but um
so he was like jolly good ginger the
night before says listen man get out of
there before pence certifies the vote
like once pence certifies the vote these
people know that it's a done deal it's
over
that's it and they'll lose their [ __ ]
minds yeah and it and you know yeah it's
hard to wrap your head around because
you're thinking this is over
right this is over dude it's [ __ ]
over like because this is all delusion
the pence thing is delusion anyways it
was like it was over
the rest of america was like oh the
election happened it's over right like
every other election i wish for the most
part dude january 6 before everything
popped off
i'm talking to people
and it wasn't over
like i spoke with sort of a finality
right
and people lost their [ __ ]
like that's off camera like i just would
make sort of comments to people but like
yeah you know brian's president oh
doesn't it suck and they would be like
he's not the president that's where it's
not [ __ ] over and i'm like wait what
are you talking about like i didn't want
to contest them but yeah all of them
felt that way and i was like
wait a second then when they stormed the
capital i was like
oh right
okay yeah no it's really not i was like
because it was so weird it was like an
alternate that's what the problem is
when i go to these rallies it takes me
two or three days because i walk away
being like did i just step into an
alternate universe
because some of them like
i come out it's like
biden was never elected covet never
really happened those covert deaths
weren't real covert deaths that you know
that's they didn't die from kovalev you
know that never happened this never
happened
you know jfk junior didn't die and you
know like all of that at once and you
just feel like you're in an alternate
timeline and it messes you up like
like it messes up my reality of like
what world do i live in that none of
this is true right
but you're like you know you're
surrounded by that the entire time and
you're like
like what this what what no
um
it takes me like a few days after i go
to these rallies i'm like what the [ __ ]
just happened
so i i watched january 6 on tv live
obviously i was i wasn't there
and but my experiences and i i want to
ask you a question about this i had a
good friend of mine he's a he's a
veteran he's retired military he called
me and he was you know because i
i called him because he is a military
veteran he's a very patriotic person
he's a conservative what you call a
conservative now he was a trump
supporter he listens to ben shapiro you
know i've had several conversations
about this
and i called him that day to see how he
felt and he was [ __ ] angry and the
reason why he was angry is because they
didn't not
pence didn't do what he should have done
you know all that [ __ ] and one of
the conversations the things that he
said to me was that you know he started
to call nazis communist
and we fought communist in the second
world war and i'm like no dude
the communist
communist
that's the thing no so
the the nazi socialist party
you know
they were socialists socialists
socialist socialists the nazis were
socialists
that's not how socialism works at all
the iraqi party was not socialist there
was like they were total free enterprise
it was totally propped up by business
interests they created a
hyper-militarized policy it was an
oligarchy is what he created
you know you know by
when people say that to me i'm like oh
so is the democratic republic of north
korea like you know like right they're
democratic right they say they are
obviously democratic because
right right exactly obviously you know
so i guess i guess my question there is
because he was in the military and i was
like whoa dude you were in the [ __ ]
military for over 20 years you surely
you heard along the way why we fought
the second world war and you're doing
this this telling well my question is
because we've seen so many members of
the military and even in our police
forces be charged with crimes on january
6 and you were there so like these
former veterans uh older younger
whatever um it actually it's like it's
kind of concerning like because mark
milley came out i think it was two or
three times in front of a microphone
before january 6 and was like remember
your oath is to a document not to a
person just remember that when you're
making the decisions you're going to
make and we even see like stuart rhodes
that guy was a former the head of those
keepers he was a former
uh veteran he's a lawyer he's uh he
can't graduate from yale gabe or
something like that yeah
yeah he was this guy's like an ivy
leaguer and here he is no again he also
shot his eye out well right right i'm
not i'm not claiming i'm not i'm not
claiming that the guy is like the most
brilliant person on the planet but what
i am saying is he functioned enough to
make it through the military function
enough to make it through law school um
you know whether he got his degree or
not but this guy this guy is being
charged with seditious conspiracy and
likely it is not the last charge that
he'll receive there's probably a
superseding indictment coming that may
bring other charges and and rake in
other people possibly members of the
congress are in trump's orbit but i
guess my question is like when you were
there that day because there was the
trump supporters and then there was
these people there like the oath keepers
who were doing military tactics there
like at the capitol like we can see
pictures of it and stuff like what was
your experience did you see those people
or were they like so much in the
background than being quiet and i mean
what what was that like um
yeah no i i saw people that were ready
to rock and roll they came with helmets
right they were ready to get tear gassed
and and do the things it wasn't just
costuming they were in their paintball
costume
right i mean a couple of them they had
there's photos of them exposing their
guns at their either from their backpack
or their way so it's like when that
claim of like there were no weapons they
were peaceful it's like no that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] they came armed and
ready for something
they were very not peaceful
and i still i still don't understand to
this day
there was no backup
i i was sitting there i was going
because part of the reason why what do
you what do you mean by that exactly no
backup for for like
capitol hill for capitol hill right
right
i mean part of the reason why i wanted
to leave quickly
once things started to get out of hand
was
oh well i don't want to be here when you
know the law enforcement people come
with the shields the tear gas and the
thing and the
and you know clears this out you know
because it's the nation's capital why
wouldn't they be on their way as we
speak
i mean they were there for hours
i mean it was when i'm i'm trying to
tell you it was very casual
outside
you know if you were if you were part of
the magna crowd it was casual you were
chilling people were there with their
dogs and they're like cracking beers and
sitting on coolers and drinks
that's why they a lot of people say like
oh it was so peaceful for them right
they were in no danger whatsoever what's
the big guy what's the big problem
because right law enforcement wasn't
cracking
back or anything um but so you're
talking about military it's the weirdest
part
i interviewed
this
father and son earlier in the day that
day
and
the son wanted to join the air force it
was always been his dream to join the
air force
so they said on camera he goes my son
wants to join the air force but he does
not want to have kamala harris as his
commander-in-chief
right
and they all thought that you know that
biden and kamala or being controlled by
china democratic party is controlled by
the ccp right
so i posted this tic tac i didn't think
much of it
military tick tock
unilaterally
was like
no you serve your country you don't
serve the president we don't want you
we're forwarding this video to the air
force so you will never get in it was
it was
wild a reporter hit me up the next day i
had their names and their town they were
from i'm like yeah
no thank you i'm let's let's not like
yeah i really don't want to trash them
to that degree
um it was interesting
they military tick tock you know which
you know is
you know conservative liberal left it's
all over the place
um
you know one would assume it's mostly
conservative but unilaterally was like
you served the country not the leader
not the president that's it and they
were like offended they were
riggered by that video didn't actually
mean anything to me i showed it to
hillary clinton we were like
did like this piss you off he's like no
but they were pissed i was i the
uh comments to that were angry as [ __ ]
dude um
it was it was wild
not angry at you angry at them i agree
i agree at the father and the son
they're like you taught your son to
serve a leader over country
you know that like how dare you like
they were mad at the father mad at the
sun wow just like that is not how the
military works and we don't want you if
that's how you think
i mean
it was funny to see a reaction like
normally when people are reacting
strongly to a video it's towards me
right right right it was like no
[ __ ] these people
it's totally different dichotomy there
so so um you mentioned before we started
recording that there might have been a
possible interview that you had to do
um after january 6 because they knew you
were there they knew you had footage and
it's the fbi sound
yeah this is public information i mean i
i've been tried i've tried to be public
about it so it's not like a gotcha thing
of someone right like oh you're an fbi
plant walter
i it literally the second the fbi left i
posted on social media that i was just
interrogated by the fbi and i said later
that like i had met with them twice and
i gave them all of my footage from that
day
you know and i came there to do comedy
did not expect to
do this so i've been very public about
that it was like here you go
not uh yeah so
yeah so they came to the door i'm at
hillary clinton's house shooting a tick
tock video they come to the door looking
for me which was so frightening because
i was like this isn't my house are you
looking for me at not my house
that's [ __ ] crazy i was like i was
actually
relaxed when they said i was relieved
when they said
we're from the fbi i'm like oh okay yeah
you waited outside
until i came to his house because i
think what they did is they couldn't
find me so they just waited outside his
house until i showed up at his house
eventually oh cause they they knew you
guys
had done was he there with you on
january yeah okay so he he they knew he
was there as well this is the first time
he had been to like a trump rally
impression
we'll get some comedy videos it's gonna
be really
funny we'll get out you know like
there's a whole thing a video of me
saying like we got to get out before
pence certifies the vote and it'll be
fine and i've been to these things in dc
and i knew how to just
exit there's a way to exit these things
in a safe way
you know like you stay off the side
streets
and you know you don't take off your
gear
uh until you're like far enough away
because that you know stuff like that
so yeah so we
we like interrogated and we're like and
he even said like oh i'm gonna make a
tick tock about this and they're like no
you actually shouldn't say anything
about it because you might get death
threats the two of us
started like falling over laughing
and we were like do you think we've we
we've been getting death threats
we're going to get more yes
big [ __ ] deal boxing us
yeah like that's been happening like
i've been i've like lost sleep and
you know missed meals because i was like
wow these people
kind of did a good great job of finding
me damn it
um but
yeah and the funny thing is to that
is that
once january 6th happened
those threats started to go down because
people
realized they were not acting on behalf
of the president of the united states of
america so so it started to kick in that
oh i might have some consequences well
you know people were acting on behalf of
the president that was their attitude
that day is that what you're saying like
when they well people realize like that
you know donald trump's not pardoning
them for
threatening me on the internet like the
people that
you know did things on january 6th went
to jail and they're going to stay there
until their sentence is done donald
trump did not intervene in any way shape
or form
so
you know there's this realization that
you know we're not i think
people who are very empowered
to act on behalf of the president
president trump and
may make tons of threats
uh just saying what's the worst one
what's the worst one you received that
was like the scarce like like you're
like holy [ __ ] this is real okay so i
you know i i said you know tons of [ __ ]
on people no prob but not not not you no
not
but
one thing i said
one day i made this one video it went
really popular and it wound up being
circulated amongst all the trumpers
trump's brother died remember that right
right yeah brother died it was like
whatever you know then i see all these
people on the internet talking about how
they're gonna pray for trump i was like
we're praying for trump today like okay
like really
um so i was like great i'm gonna go in
front of a church and i'm like let's
pray this isn't funny everyone let's
pray
i pray that his brother and
donald and his brother are reunited
you know
and that
set off a [ __ ]
the people that came out of the woodwork
like some guy was making a tick tock
like and it was like he was his family
was there and he was in his trailer you
could hear them in the background and i
was like
and he
had he looked like he if you were like
casting a movie for like a guy that
lived in a trailer that's him he was
like i took and because i had taken that
lord's name in vain
and i had wished is that the lord being
like god or lord being trump
oh you [ __ ] up it was a devil yeah and
so like
they were like that was like i was like
because i you know i had gotten so much
there's like a level of hatred that
you're sort of used to
and when it exceeds that you're like wow
that's a that's a lot
um right and you had people contacting
me and making videos that i was like
like wow like you're saying my name and
it's terrifying and they're openly
threatening me like openly
they're gonna find me in the city
they're gonna come to new york city and
find me
holy [ __ ] and i was like
you know i've seen some some other
people have like said that and i've met
done comment replies showing their
comment being like you know i can just
tell you where i'm going to be in the
city you want to do that
um where people are less empowered to
talk like that when they realize that
they're not doing it on behalf of the
the president of the united states
so that was
a big difference that i saw
before and after january 6.
it was almost a relief in some ways that
these people if they were going to act
like that they were realizing that they
were doing that alone right they didn't
have the power of
you know the united states government
behind them right right it was all it
was all uh over at that point
people were very comfortable making
videos like a
video saying i'm going to come to new
york city and find him that's a tick
tock video saying you're going to come
to the city and find me how creative i
mean you know but also
so dumb why would you openly like as
someone who's going to potentially
attack assault or whatever
against you why would you just on the
internet say hey guys if anyone's
wondering where i'm going to be i'm
going to be driving down to new york
city i'm going to find walter at his
house and i'm gonna do something
all right peace i mean again we talked
about this before the interview but it's
the same dumbasses that went to january
6 and they were like oh look at marie
and they're like posting to facebook and
when they spread [ __ ] on the wall and
all this stuff and they're like how'd
you find me and it's like how do you
think it's it's like the law and order
episode with like it's like the first
suspect they interview and it's like
then they like leave them alone once
they realize the person's an idiot it's
like
it's like you know the first 15 minutes
of law and order it's like i wasn't
going to kill her i just said i was
going to kill her on the internet
what are you talking about i can't just
say like no actually saying that is uh
sort of a crime right it's my freedom of
speech
oh you can't say anything in this
country anymore it's like well actually
you can you know you just can't say that
it's like it's it's been the same way
for years it's just right you know you
didn't you didn't have to consequence
[Laughter]
right right well you know
so so i have a few other videos that i
want to ask you about but did gabe tell
you we play trivia here on the podcast
we play trivia no
so so today you're gonna play gabe gabe
in a trivia game so let's let's play
trivia
[Music]
here's the rules there's gonna be five
questions right you're each gonna get a
chance for the question you're gonna
ring in with your buzzer your thumbs up
that's your buzzer
and the first the first one to ring in
actually gets
gets a chance at the question if you get
the question wrong your opponent gets a
chance at that question each question is
worth one point the person with the most
uh points at the end wins nothing so we
just like to have fun so here we go
question number one
on april 12 1945 president franklin d
roosevelt died
while during his term in office making
who the 33rd president of the united
states is it a dwight d eisenhower is it
b harry truman is it c herbert hoover or
is it d calvin coolidge uh that was a
false flag uh by the deep state franklin
and delano roosevelt didn't die
okay
was still alive and
yeah so next question
that is that is incorrect gabe the
question goes to you do you want me to
repeat the answer
dwight d eisenhower is it b harry truman
c herbert hoover or d calvin coolidge
uh uh
a
no it is not a it is b harry truman
harry
the the the
the vice president from missouri
is the is the correct
where'd you read that it's the deep
okay all right i see this this is like
sort of this rigged liberal tribute game
oh we got the answers off of wikipedia
all right sure
okay okay so next next deep state
question number two
which classic cocktail includes vodka
triple sec cranberry juice and lime
juice is it a an old-fashioned is it b a
mojito is it c a margarita or is it d a
cosmopolitan so the cosmopolitan so was
invented by the deep state uh
because the adrenochrome
it was like the see the
chrome and it tastes a little like
chemically so it was meant to sort of
lighten that that taste a little bit
so you could drink adrenochrome
so your answer is it's invented by cnn
uh
so the answer is which one is it a
old-fashioned b mojito c margarita or d
cosmopolitan d the cnn okay okay the cnn
that is correct
you know i've had one of those with the
adrenal chrome uh with a splash of
pedialyte in there it's great oh my god
so it's just a splash just a splat just
like a pool
okay not too much you don't want to
overpower the flavor just a little bit
yeah you know because you know you
remember like you know all these mixed
drinks came about during prohibition
and everything yeah the same same
concept adrenochrome question number
three
dave bowie
released space oddity on the 11th july
of which year
a
1969
b
1972 c 1974
or d
1976
okay so yes um during the uh iran has
iran iranian hostage crisis
um the deal with uh iran
uh they uh
yeah that's how he released it
so so the iran contra scandal no no no
no no no the iranian uh well the iran
conscious scandal was you know then
though his subsequent album but um
during the hostage crisis that was sort
of a deal it was sort of
based on the yeah it was the be it was
the b side is what it was okay so which
year was that in that they did that
1969 1972 1974 1976 is this theory
people think that the iran in hostage
thing happened in the late 70s but
i mean
all the humans know it happened in 1969
that is correct that is correct 1969
is the correct answer
uh walter with two points
okay um let's go to let's see let's go
oh here we go which of these famous
players
isn't one of the top 10 nba players of
the 1980s
is it a magic johnson
is it b julius irving is it c michael
jordan or is it d vince carter who is
the biggest nba star in the asia which
which of these players isn't one of the
top 10 nba players of the 1980s
isn't oh isn't yes
so it's deserving
that is incorrect gabe it is your it is
your deep state um
throw to all right so it was irving
jordan
magic johnson or d vince carter a magic
johnson vince carter that is correct d
is the correct answer vince carter is
the correct answer so we got we got four
questions in
walter with two deep state correct
answers gabe with one we had to throw
one out uh so question number five
um what was the highest grossing film of
the 2000s
is it a lord of the rings the return of
the king
is it b avatar
is it c the dark knight or is it b
r d d excuse me harry potter and the uh
philosopher's stone avatar avatar is
correct
we have a tie we have a tie do you guys
want to go to a tiebreaker to win
nothing yeah oh my god let's do it yeah
okay congratulations
tie breaker for the win
where would you win nothing the boston
tea party happened in which year on
december 16th now this is a big
government conspiracy probably
um 1673
1773
1873
or was it 1973
1973 why why do you say 1973
i mean because you know i've done my own
research
[Laughter]
and i don't i don't rely on uh
pack
to tell me
uh american history
right
where did
let me assume where did you read about
tea party
these are on ultimate quiz
questions.com i'm totally not stealing
these off the internet
okay so big tech you know fed you these
these questions
and you know they're you're just blindly
just going he's like oh yeah sure
big tech told you when the tea party
boston tea party happened and you're
just like sure
i'm not saying he's wrong but he is he
is kind of getting me to agree with him
well you know i mean i mean
what he's saying is true to some degree
gabe do you have an answer for the
sudden death is it
is it a 1673 b 1773
d
1873 or
excuse me
c 1873 or d 1973
my my brain is mush now from the um
oh yeah
you've realized you know that big tack
is sort of
telling you all this stuff uh
i'm gonna i'm gonna say
1773. that is correct that is correct
gabe you win trivia you win the game you
are the big deep state winner
um obviously walter is a little hurt
over the um some of the answers that
were there i mean you know it's fine i
mean i'm on a liberal podcast you guys
just believe anything
oh it's like oh yeah
you definitely you definitely are on the
antifa podcast here on d tony michaels
so thanks for playing the game stick
around we'll be we'll be right back
[Music]
want to tell us where we can where we
can find you and tell the audience where
they can find you on all these uh okay
so i
listen i have enough followers on all
these other platforms go to my youtube
okay good longer form you know you'll
see like more condensed stuff of what i
do you know you'll see like a full rally
like you know if you want to watch 20
tick tocks of a rally that i went to
go to tick tock you know go to my tick
tock for walter masterson but if you
want to watch more condensed just go to
my youtube walter masterson okay so
everyone go and subscribe and click the
bell notification and hit the comments
down below you know whatever you're
supposed to do on youtube and follow
walter there thank you walter for
joining us come back any time any time
oh dude i know you've got like piles and
mountains of storms yeah oh yeah i love
chalmers and gabe thanks for your help
the other week oh yeah i'm i'm happy you
know great
dude um
so yeah dude always appreciate it man
thank you thanks for joining us thanks
for joining us we'll be right back after
this after this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
drupists mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
what a great interview hilarious
i'm surprised they even made it through
it i don't know i did some at some
points i wasn't even making it through
walter is so goddamn funny
uh again there's an extended version of
this interview that we will be playing
um hopefully sometime this weekend
i'm not sure exactly uh exactly when
we'll get there but we will get we will
get the extended version of the
interview with walter out um there's
probably almost another whole hour
of walter almost another hour of
walter's hilarious tales
of the trump rallies january 6 um you
know
it's funny as funny as some of it is
uh walter really was like there in the
thick of january 6
and um you know we all we all we all
know
that january 6 is is a big deal
um in that we're seeing more and more
people indicted uh more people were
arrested apparently in the last few days
and charged with other charges we've
seen the very first january 6
insurrectionist
be uh found guilty of all charges that
they were charged with
from the the federal prosecutor in the
federal courts uh yeah i believe it was
yesterday uh just this week we also had
the very first
uh plea deal with conspiracy charges
uh i actually i think that was last week
that we've seen those those charges with
the oath keeper uh roger stone's
uh official bodyguard that the oath
keepers uh awarded him on january 6
which you know when when a person who
was protecting roger stone on january 6
like all day was with him all day pleads
guilty please guilty
to con conspiracy of sedition
and he was right next to roger stone all
day yeah you know
smells kind of funny smells kind of
funny
the other thing to think about too
is
if you really think about roger stone in
his relationship with donald trump
if you think about it
it really does start to look like roger
stone
and the oath keepers that might have
been one way that they were
communicating with the president of the
united states as he sat and watched the
siege on the capitol to go hang mike
pence and to overturn the election so he
could be dictator the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup as it were
and it just seems kind of funny that an
oath keeper who is charged in the
seditious conspiracy with stuart rhodes
who is giving orders
to those oath keepers for the qrf we've
had dakota adams stewart rhodes
estranged son on the show and tasha
adams his estranged wife
we've had them on the show talking about
this that stuart rhodes was giving the
orders we see the reports he was giving
the orders to the oath keepers that day
if something went awry if something went
a mess if there was chaos ensued and if
trump
the president united states would have
declared the insurrection act and
declared martial law that they were
going to act
and it just is
it's kinda got the stench
kind of got the stench of that t word
treason
when an oath keeper who has pled guilty
suspicious conspiracy
was protecting roger stone
who is one text away from the president
of the united states one phone call away
you don't think that roger stone and
donald trump talked on the phone that
day
you don't think they ever talk on the
phone they're probably still talking on
they might be talking on the phone right
now as we speak
you know trying to figure out how
they're gonna get out of this mess who
knows
but walter was right in the thick of it
right there and you you heard what he
said that these people who were you know
on the lawn who didn't actually go into
building then to say oh i had no idea
what was going on i didn't know what was
going on i was outside i was just i'm
just i'm just a lonely bystan they knew
exactly what was going on the news was
spreading like wildfire
yes there was different parts of the
insurrection where the people on the
lawn they were a lot calmer because
there wasn't violence happening out
there they weren't destroying property
out there on the lawn
but as you worked your way inside it got
more and more violent it got more and
more destructive and
it got more and more uh seditious and
treasonous as it seems
and different people were there for
different reasons as he said
but so check out this this weekend we
will air uh the extended version of
walter's interview again there's
probably about 45 or 50 more minutes
that he talks about not just not just
the insurrection but also
the trump rallies which is some of the
greatest stories he also tells a story
about being on the beach
with marjorie taylor greene and matt
gatz
which is a great story as well so check
that out check that out this weekend we
will air that we will post it on twitter
we'll try to get it out on all the
socials
um and again subscribe to the youtube
channel so you don't miss it you do not
want to miss uh the extended version of
that interview so subscribe to the
youtube channel or check out twitch
or follow us on twitter at
tonymichaelspod also follow me and gabe
at the tony michaels and i am gabe
sanchez
so you catch that
we got a lot that to get to in the
tweety tweets and the tourney trends we
got some stuff trending um duckduckgo
you guys know what duckduckgo is
i mean
it's like the wish.com of google
apparently apparently they have [ __ ] the
bed here and they're gonna turn their
backs on all their their trump humping
fans
uh and they're going to give a big
middle finger to russia and russian
disinformation i mean what's the point
of even going to duckduckgo now if
they're not going to propagate russian
disinformation what the [ __ ] the point
i don't know so we'll get to that um
also let's see who else is in the news
um
caught madison cawthorne you guys have
probably seen madison gothards in the
news
but uh let's let's go to the uh
let's go to the timeline here
well first before we start
because we do have the bonehead of the
week so i want to show you that but
let's start the countdown and then we'll
get into the bone end of the week and
the tweety tweets and the trendy grins
for the shitless roundup start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome and welcome welcome back to the
show and to the [ __ ] this roundup where
we ran up all the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends of the day
we're excited to round them all up you
know tomorrow tomorrow's friday and you
guys know what happens on friday here on
the tony michaels podcast we do the [ __ ]
list roundup in the first hour we do
bonehead of the week
bonet of the week in the second hour
let's go to the timeline i'll take you
to the poll here let's go down and see
if we can find the pole here's the pole
here is the pole let's make it a bigger
so you can see let's see what our
results are so far looks like uh we got
we got donald john trump
up at the top representative madison
cawthorne hopefully not a representative
very long
and then we have the governor of florida
ron desantis
death sanchez
uh you guys probably know exactly why
these people are on here donald john
trumps could be on on here every single
[ __ ] week there's a couple reasons
why he's on madison cothran we're going
to get into the treaty tweets and the
training trends here because he is still
trending
for the dumb [ __ ] he did and then there
is governor ron desantis which we know
is the reason why he's on here
number one he is a [ __ ] bonehead
through and through but
he signed and they passed and signed the
don't say gay bill
um ostracizing
and uh discriminating against
gay children in florida
um this is ridiculous uh they're gonna
and texas is trying to out florida
florida
by passing the trains bill uh idaho has
one uh missouri has another anti-woman's
bill look
this stuff this type of fascism
i'm telling you this type of fascism
it is designed to get these people in a
situation where they're okay
with genocide i know that sounds a
far-fetched
i know that sounds way off and you're
thinking tony jesus christ those are big
words and they are big words
but they're always projecting always
always always always
and the the russian propaganda that is
now coming out of russia about ukraine
is that ukraine is committing genocide
and they're always projecting and
they're they're believing some of this
[ __ ] in this country now
they're believing some of this [ __ ]
but if you don't believe that this is a
slow walk
to that type of fascism
where they they cast out
people in our society
because of who they are
the color of their skin
who they want to be
the choices that they can make
and killing their liberty you don't
think they're not gonna come for your
children
you don't think that they're going to
eventually i mean they ban the word gay
why can't they ban other words jesus
christ we had in russia this week we had
vladimir putin banned the word war and
now in america we have ron desantis
banning the word gay in florida
think about this
think about this for a second this is
the no cancel culture party
the freedom
party
but you're not free to say the word gay
well [ __ ] them [ __ ] ron desantis and
[ __ ] all the gqp you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you gay gay
gay gay gay
say it loud i think they should protest
and say gay [ __ ] them
teach these fascists a [ __ ] lesson
and what freedom and liberty looks like
and if you don't believe
that ron desantis
donald trump madison cawthorne that are
on this list here if you don't think
that these fascist [ __ ] don't
want what russia has you just listen to
the words of donald trump about kim
jong-un
oh i love him so much i wish my people
would have been would have
been fawning over me terrified of me
that i would murder them if they didn't
do what i said
that's what he's saying he wants to be a
dictator we've seen that schlub
stephanie grisham
or grissom however you say her last name
on the view as a co-host what the [ __ ]
does the view got her as a co-host on
for jesus christ
say that yeah he loved the dictators
because they wanted to kill the free
press dictators kill press and he wanted
to be able to kill the press
folks i'm telling you
i'm telling you right now this type of
fascism that they want and they're
perpetuating their passing laws that
type of fascism
leads to death
is what it leads to that's where they're
headed
you don't believe me just just go read
some threads about what they said about
people coming over the border while
trump was president of the united states
we'll just shoot him is what they said
you mean the women and the children yeah
sure they're criminals too
they have they have been
making sure to put this delusion in
these people's brains and this
is the type of grooming down in florida
in texas and these other places where
they're trying to take away people's
liberty
this is the type of [ __ ]
that is grooming
to ostracize these people to turn people
into criminals because of who they are
not because of what they've done or what
they haven't done or what they should do
or whatever
just because of who they
are
so vote for bonehead of the week
it looks like uh it's going to be a
really close race
between the two florida men as [ __ ]
okay let's go back to the timeline here
we got a lot of walter interview stuff
here uh so again check out the uh walter
interview this week in the extended
version we'll get that out
uh
oh here we go mayo i don't know mayo's
still here she was here just a minute
ago
on the twitch channel uh mayo says
madison cawthron is driving the crazy
train and he doesn't have a license
as you know madison gothard get another
traffic violation for
having uh driving on a suspended license
i really i honestly this is the least of
my worries
about madison cawthorne
it really is it is the least of my
[ __ ] worries
about madison cawthorne
um
here here we go here's the [ __ ] don't
say gay bill [ __ ]
uh keith edwards post this screenshot
of this nazi that's right she's a
[ __ ] nazi you don't believe me go
watch the [ __ ] interview with her
brother curtis
on midas touch's channel go watch it
he tells you she's a [ __ ]
nazi
he says of course this is where these
laws are all heading
it's about codifying gay people as child
predators
and look look look what they say
liberals are sexually grooming
elementary students
fascist type [ __ ]
these are words
that lead to the death of people that
they don't like
uh midas touch says this is so dangerous
it is it's very dangerous rhetoric it's
very dangerous uh to say this about a
group of people
uh let's see here
they do do here is another tweet uh
midas mighty matt
i posted this i want uh to read this one
this this uh
puts it in perspective
and everyone should go retweet this
uh from matt
for those not aware and i'm not sure how
that's possible grooming in quotes
in the context of don't say gay bill is
a term used in regards to pedophiles
this just further propagates and and a
false narrative
that lgbtq plus are pedophiles
we just want to be included in society
simple
listen that is what they're trying to do
they're trying to ostracize these people
from society they're trying to make it
okay
for their ilk to ostracize to cast away
these people from society these are
human [ __ ] beings
who cares what what your
why why do these freedom
idiots these convoy manga trump pumping
[ __ ] who claim to love freedom
give two shits about who someone else
loves
because they're fascist
that's why
they're fascist why do you think they
love putin putin murders gay people
putin has gay people murdered
in russia for being gay
you don't think this is a slow walk
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
better start paying attention
better start
thank you matt for your tweet
uh i seen this uh earlier this clip on
uh c-span
and uh nancy pelosi was being asked
questions about uh the airspace being
closed in planes
and uh she says this about tanks this is
great listen to this when i see that
that those tanks at 40 miles of tanks
i'd like to take out those tanks when i
i'd like to take out those tanks she's
like when i see that 40 miles of tanks
yeah i'd like to i like to take out
those things oh my gosh
okay here here is uh andrew has this
andrew wartman has this uh stephanie
grisham
or griss ham i'm not sure exactly how
she says it is garbage for sitting on
what she knew
and no one should buy her book but her
revelation that trump would tell putin
i'm gonna act tough in front of you of
the cameras and then we'll have a real
conversation that [ __ ] matters
that [ __ ] matters you got to hear
this [ __ ] [ __ ] it is [ __ ] gross
it's [ __ ] gross oh yeah oh well she
she's come out she's she's speaking
against trump oh yeah well after
after it mattered
after they tried to sell us the big lie
continuing to sell the big lie
[ __ ] her why the [ __ ] does the view have
her on there in the first place
they should have just interviewed her
and and got this at her they didn't need
to have her as a co-host
as people
maybe some don't know
stephanie grissom
was the press secretary at one point
most people don't even know that
like they don't even know she was the
actual press secretary she was an
assistant i think a assistant press
secretary or press secretary to the
first lady and then uh when sarah
huckabee sanders and no one else would
do it she did it she did the job as
press secretary now she didn't actually
do the job and what i mean by that what
i mean by that is she didn't actually
give press briefings in the press room
of the white house
she refused to give press briefings and
the reason why is because she wanted to
make sure that she could go on the view
and no one knew who the [ __ ] who the
[ __ ] she was
because if she would have came out and
spewed her [ __ ] lies in front of a
microphone in front of a camera
she wouldn't be on the [ __ ] view
but instead she spewed her lines lies on
press releases and pressed memos instead
of getting out in front of the
microphone in the camera
she spun
this [ __ ] treasonous bastards lies
propaganda
the entire time
and then she stands by
after knowing what she knows
and then
after
after all that after all the big lie
we've been going through this for an
entire [ __ ] year and just now just
now that her book is released
here's what she has to say
um i think that he would have a
completely hands-off approach i think
he'd be like go on in there you know he
he really
admired putin and i saw that firsthand i
saw him say to putin hey i'm going to be
tough on you in front of the cameras you
understand and once the cameras are gone
we'll have a real conversation
she's saying he said that of course he
said that we know he [ __ ] says that
he says that to everyone
i want i want everyone to think i'm a
tough guy because i'm not i am
definitely
not what everyone thinks i am
everyone knows he does that [ __ ] look at
his hair his [ __ ] spray tan
the shoes that he wears everyone thinks
that he leans forward because he has
dementia or some [ __ ] those are his
[ __ ] shoes he has like six inch lifts
in his shoes
the reason why he couldn't walk down
that [ __ ] ramp that day is because
his [ __ ] his penny loafers that he
had on they got [ __ ] four inch lifts
in him and if he runs down that ramp he
would lose his shoe
and people would know that he has lifts
everything about this [ __ ] is a
lie
all of it
all of it he's not a [ __ ] billionaire
he's not [ __ ] rich he doesn't own all
those [ __ ] buildings he doesn't own
them that's all [ __ ] he doesn't own
those golf courses
he doesn't own those country clubs
russian banks own those [ __ ]
he's broke as a [ __ ] joke
he can't get his [ __ ] social media
company just like he couldn't get his
stakes going just like he couldn't get
his winery going
just like he couldn't hang on to trump
university everything the [ __ ]
bankrupt
casinos
if there's one [ __ ] business in this
country that you could run and
guaranteeing not to go bankrupt it's a
[ __ ] casino
he bankrupt the [ __ ]
he's a fraud always has been always will
be
and we're supposed to be surprised that
he looked at vladimir putin said hey
make sure i i want you to know don't go
rough on me because i'm going to try to
act tough in front of the cameras for
you but when we're behind closed doors
i'll put my knee pads on oh we'll be
we'll be perfect
i'll i'll i'll give you anything you
want
anything anything mr putin
anything
that he said that yeah um that was him
going tough
on putin
well exactly
exactly um and so you know and he took
putin's word over our own national
intelligence so i think he would
absolutely just be like go for it and
then i actually think he would probably
talk about how tough he is and be in awe
yeah of of what he's doing as he's as he
has been the last last couple of weeks
it's just like i i you know you want to
put on a tree you know you know who and
putin k-i-s-s-i-n-g
that's what it
that's what it feels like you know it
feels
i've never in my lifetime
seen any
american president
talk about
russia and what they've done
in such glowing time i mean it blew my
mind why do you i this is speculation i
suppose but why do you think he had um
that kind of relationship with putin
some people say it's because he
maybe had business interests there or
wanted business interest there or
perhaps putin had something on him
what are your thoughts um i think
honestly i think he feared him i think
he was afraid of him i think that the
man intimidated him um because putin
he's a scary man i mean just frankly i
think he was afraid of him i also think
he admired him greatly i think he wanted
to be able to
kill whoever yeah you know that's it
right there he wanted to kill whoever
you don't need any more [ __ ] words
from her
that's exactly what he wanted that's
exactly why he admires putin that's
exactly why he admires kim jong-un
it's because he wants to kill the press
he wants to be able to murder people
who he wants who's in his way
now he's a weak piece of [ __ ]
so i i doubt that this guy could ever be
a murderous dictator he's a [ __ ]
but
that's what he wants he wants to be a
tough guy
speaking of of
boneheaded
statements that
absolutely hold up [ __ ] putin i said
this [ __ ] hates windmills more
than he hates putin what a dumb bastard
this guy can't even keep his plane in
the air
this guy's supposed to be a [ __ ]
billionaire this guy's supposed to be
[ __ ] rich
the richest [ __ ] ever and he
can't keep his [ __ ] plane in the air
a real billionaire would just go buy a
new [ __ ] plane you [ __ ] twit
not rehab his broken old piece of [ __ ]
that he can't [ __ ] keep together more
than two [ __ ] days
then he asked his [ __ ] supporters to
help pay to fix the [ __ ]
you ever had that you ever had the guy
on your block
that that their their car is always
[ __ ] broke down and they're working
on it in the [ __ ] street and they're
always that you know they're asking you
for favors
you know come help me do this come help
me do that
but you know if you're neighborly you do
but you wouldn't go over and say he
wouldn't say
hey can you give me can you give me 400
hours to fix my car
give me 400
like i'll help you but 400 bucks jesus
christ
his [ __ ] supporters think he's rich
and they also think he needs them to
donate to [ __ ] fix his broke-ass
plane the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
this guy's so [ __ ] twisted up listen
listen to this [ __ ] interview we're
gonna we're gonna break this down real
quick listen to this [ __ ] uh it would
have never happened and we did talk
about it i mean he definitely
wanted ukraine loved ukraine of course
he's talking about putin here
he loved ukraine he wanted ukraine it
would have never happened you were
giving him ukraine you dumb [ __ ]
like you were you were giving him
ukraine
you were giving it to him
like nato is the thing that stands in
the eu
is the ending in america
is the one thing that stands in between
putin and ukraine
and you were gonna tear all that down to
give him ukraine you dumb [ __ ]
would never have happened yes what do
you see happening next then because it's
okay i want to point something out here
apparently this is like a i don't know
like a a podcast a and i think it's a
ufc like a wrestling podcast
this is a really weird setting it's
almost like a courtroom or something
like he's under oath but there's a box
of beer here and a lot of people thought
it was a box of chicken looks like a box
of beer it really is it really is
[ __ ] weird
that a former president united states
can only book an interview on a podcast
like this like this would be and i'm not
saying barack obama wouldn't come on
here but it would be like if barack
obama could only
book an interview with me
let's let's continue it seems like the
tensions are high what how does this all
end is this going to be like a long-term
thing how do you see unfolding well
asking about ukraine this guy
is ridiculous as it may be he's asking a
question about ukraine like how long is
it going to last like he's trying to get
an answer out of someone
who is supposed to be abreast of
national security issues the former
president united states he's trying to
get him
to answer a valid question that a former
president would maybe answer about the
conflict
of vladimir putin
committing war crimes in ukraine
and this is what the [ __ ] he comes up
with and i said this a long time ago if
this happens uh we are
uh
playing right into their hands green
energy
the windmills they don't work
they're too expensive they kill what
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
he's asking about the [ __ ] war you
dumb [ __ ] all the birds they
ruin your landscapes and yet the
environmentalists love the windmills and
i've been preaching this for years
the windmills and i had them way down
but the windmills are the most gives a
[ __ ] about what else he has to say i
don't give a [ __ ] but look at this guy's
face
look at this guy's face when he pan to
him what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
windmills
this guy doesn't know about national
security issues this guy doesn't know
about in geopolitical conflicts in
ukraine and russia he just knows to ask
the question
but he also knows when donald trump
brings up [ __ ] windmills he's like
what the [ __ ]
i'm ridiculous
ridiculous
ridiculous
okay let's uh
here's another [ __ ] video that i want
to show you
um speaking of putin's puppets
and putin's little minions we have
steve sloppy scabby steve bannon
on trader tv that's what we call it here
trader tv let's see what this seditious
treasonous piece of [ __ ] has to say no
republican
should vote for any money for ukraine
yeah we understand that you're from
ukraine
as much as your heart wants to help
the poor women and children who are
bombed and shelled every day he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about the women and children
he's excited that the women and children
are being bombed
look at him look at that thing a face of
despair
that's a face of scabby glee right that
picture right there in the new york
times the horrible agony of the
ukrainian people not one penny i hate to
be an adult
i hate to be an adult what is an adult
an adult would actually understand
what's going on here the thing i [ __ ]
the thing that's really [ __ ] gross
about this
about this whole scene
is look at behind him behind steve
bannon here he's talking about women and
children being bombed and killed by a
murderous [ __ ] dictator who is
committing war crimes against innocent
civilians in ukraine and he's got a
picture of jesus
well isn't that [ __ ] cute
got a picture of jesus behind him
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
okay
uh you've seen gabe posted this a lot of
people were wondering if this was real
or not you know
i said paging daniel dale
you guys know daniel dale is um he's a
fact checker for cnn and he's fact
checked gabe a couple times him and gabe
just
have not
got along here but gabe posted this
statement this is the statement from
donald trump about his airplane official
update of trump force one
do you remember trump force one before
becoming the greatest president of all
time i travel the country my plane known
as trump force one how many times do you
think he he wants to say trump force one
i have a very important update about my
point but i need to trust that you won't
share it with anyone
it's a big secret my team is building a
brand new trump force one which they're
not they're not building a brand new and
they're they're [ __ ] working on his
broke broke ass busted ass plane
the construction of this plane has been
under wraps not even the fake news media
knows about it
and i can't wait to unveil it for
everyone to see this is [ __ ] real
let me take down the banner here so you
can see it
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] real i'm not
kidding you
this was in an email
a trump email
to his [ __ ] followers
it's real
he's begging people for money for his
plane this is supposedly a billionaire
worth like eight billion nine billion
dollars some dumb [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of here a person worth eight billion
dollars doesn't have to beg their
[ __ ] supporters to pay their [ __ ]
mechanic bill on their plane because
that's what it's happening jesus christ
[ __ ] ridiculous
but no
a lot of people question if that was
real it's [ __ ] real
it's real gabe says trump i'm broke pay
for my new plane
maga okay i'll refinance my home
again
and again and again and again and again
to give you money how how long until
maga goes broke
okay let's move on here let's let's go
to the trendy joints in the tree treats
we are 50 minutes
into the second hour we had a great
interview with walter uh which uh it's
delayed the shitless roundup but we are
in the shitless roundup now
uh madison gawthorne of course he's
still trending
um
let's see aaron says something here
maybe he's trending for something other
than the license thing i thought he was
trending because he was uh uh driving on
a suspended license that's what i
thought
am i wrong i mean i thought that's why
he was trending but aaron says putin
propagandist
madison cawthorne called president
zielinski a thug what the [ __ ] are you
kidding me
salinsky is a hero catherine is a joke
what
are you [ __ ] me he called him a thug
where is this is this on [ __ ] video
please tell me it's on video aaron uh by
the way aaron i think is gonna come on
tomorrow um in the first part of the
hour and give us uh some updates about
ukraine things that he knows there uh
give us a little bit of reporting on
ukraine and the the uh some of the war
crimes that are being committed there
and uh
aaron uh has family in ukraine uh he has
communication ties to ukraine and he's
been following it very closely because
of that so he's gonna come on tomorrow
for just a little bit and give us a a
little bit of a breakdown of some of
that stuff so uh look forward to
tomorrow with aaron parnez
as he comes on let's see if we can find
a video of this uh
car thorn saying this is this in an
article or is this him saying it oh here
it is yep here it is ted lou has it i
commend the united states naval academy
for having the foresight to reject gop
man representative madison cawthorne who
had lied about getting accepted to the
academy let's retweet that let's give
congressman lou is
his credit here if you read it you get
credit uh republican accountability
project has this video
of that um
fascist [ __ ]
uh zielinski is a thug remember that the
ukrainian government is incredibly
corrupt and incredibly evil and has been
pushing woke ideologies
what the [ __ ]
okay so this is really [ __ ] weird
this is really this is really [ __ ]
weird
so
they're saying that
that
they're pushing woke ideologies right
okay
and then on the same breath the russian
government which they're believing
saying there's genocide and all how is
genocide woke
that's not woke
oh my god it just it really it really
shows you the delusional pattern that
they're in and really the dangerous
delusion that a lot of people are under
in this country including members of
[ __ ] congress
i i don't think this [ __ ] is
smart enough to know what he's doing
everyone will claim oh he knows what
he's doing he knows what no he he's just
a stupid [ __ ] fascist who can't think
for himself and will say whatever he
wants to say because he thinks he's
protected because he's a white dude
madison cawthorne you're in a wheelchair
if you don't think you're you will be
one of the first that the fascists will
come after because let's face it they're
they're after trans children
they're after gay people
they're gonna they're gonna get rid of
them
they're that's what they're doing
they're they're gonna get rid of women
who need medical procedures to save
their lives to leave states to go to a
state where that procedure is legal
states rights type [ __ ] right
you don't think you don't think
that physically handicapped people are
the next people on the list
you don't think they can't even [ __ ]
fathom making sure that children who are
gay or trans in the lgbt community are
safe inside their schools
with their identity
they won't even make sure they're
[ __ ] safe what would make you believe
that they would take someone with
physical disabilities mental
disabilities or disabilities in general
and make sure they're safe too
what on [ __ ] this planet would make
you believe that seeing the pattern of
these murderous death cult fascists
what
answer me
let's listen to what this [ __ ] has to
say this is so they can defend
themselves better but remember that
zielinski is a thug remember the
ukrainian government is incredibly
corrupt and it is incredibly evil and it
has been pushing woke ideologies and it
really does the new all [ __ ] lies now
granted the russian democracy is not
perfect
and yes ins in past the ukrainian
democracy has been held together by
threads
but is it it is a democracy even still
with the corruption
it is a democracy and yes all
democracies aren't perfect
but for this guy
the call is
zielinski a thug oh [ __ ]
jesus dude
you're bark you're barking up the wrong
tree or punching the wrong dead tree
as it were
[ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this nazi i'll call
him a nazi he's a nazi
madison claw thorn is a [ __ ] nazi and
that's why he's on the bone end of the
week
here it is here it is so go vote
at
tony michael's pod
follow us
follow us on twitter at tonymichaelspod
and you can find
you can find the poll there go vote for
uh donald john trump for his plane
problems and his money his his
maintenance
his mechanic bill problems
and also the windmill comment
and go vote for madison catherine for
his license being expired and being on
the wrong side of history
thinking zielinski is the thug
and then definitely definitely go check
out ron desantis on the pole that
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] for the don't say
gay bill where these fascists
just can't help themselves
it's a dead heat
go vote you still have all afternoon and
all evening to vote we will do the
bonehead of the week tomorrow
in the second hour of the show
in the second hour of the show we will
do
we will do the bone head of the week
where we go through
each one of these
these nazis on this bone end of the week
list
okay we got that we're 57 8 58 minutes
into the hour we get
a few more minutes let's see what else
is trending so we uh trump was right
about everything come on
you you misspelled nothing okay uh let's
see what else is trending duckduckgo
again is trending uh because they're
taking russian propaganda off their uh
their search engine which i don't know
what's going to be on there if they take
down misinformation i'm not really sure
what's going to be on duckduckgo let's
see what's in the for you before we
leave
fat wolverine oh that sounds that sounds
inflation
inflation you know they're gonna make a
big deal out of that people's convoy oh
that should be
exhilarating you should go check out all
these trendy trends and tweety tweets
today
and join us tomorrow tomorrow again
we're going to do bonehead of the week
in the second hour on fridays is
bonehead of the weekday we go through
the bonehead of the week poll
but you guys vote we have dishonorable
mentions we have the alpha cuck of the
week
who knows what it'll be you should go to
the poll on at tony michael's pod and
give us who you think the dishonorable
mention and the alpha cuck should be for
the week
don't forget tomorrow in the front of
the first hour we're gonna have aaron
parnez on to give us some updates about
uh the conflict in ukraine and some of
the war crimes that are happening and
some of the updates
from the conflict there that vladimir
putin uh is uh has gone into a country
that he's not supposed to be in that
murderous [ __ ] dictator so aaron will
give us the lowdown tomorrow morning
gabe will join us tomorrow for bone head
of the week
again every single weekday noon eastern
11 central right here on youtube twitter
twitch
join us every single day we're so happy
to be part of the midas touch
network now
so shout out to the minus mighty as
jordy would say
and really until tomorrow
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] him
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking